thank you thank you very much
if clothes make the man then certainly
the costume makes the actor the costume
designer is essential and vital what is
there you create the look of the
character without which no performance
can succeed there's is a monumental job
for there must be not only artists but
technicians researchers and historians
I'm very happy to help honor these
tireless talented men and women whom
I've always been inspired by and have so
much depended on for achievement in
costume design the nominees are Agee
gerard Rogers for the color purple
Albert Wolski for the journey of natty
Gann
Malena can onero for the out of Africa
Don Feld Prizzi's honor and Amy wada for
run
and the winner is ami vada
why not can you Donna sure what I do not
that you may know your favorite things I
have never dreamed I could receive this
golden hour but anyway I doesn't notice
you see what I notice this figure
doesn't need my costume kudos can't
imagine a giant Rasta stuff but not - ah
no guy get a thong - I thank you
especially the mr. ozawa
and crew were acted together so stare at
the sea no animal can suspect also to my
wife to my husband
thank you very very much
you